MMM.
All right,
bye.
I see.
Hey,
we've the inimitable and disdain Dr. Jordan Peterson.
If you haven't been following the last couple of years,
he might be hiding on Rankin serving some of the sixth string dimension.
So I don't want to go into too much detail,
but I'm very honored and privileged to be able to have a bit of a conversation
with them today.
Um,
there's just one or two questions that I'd like to ask you with regards to the
fiasco.
We've,
the kept the caffeine human interview and talking about journalistic integrity
and how that sort of rent up.
Um,
what you were talking about yesterday in the VIP area about the media now
sending out a memo saying this is not how to do interviews.
What are your thoughts?
Can you elaborate on the demise of journalistic integrity or the death of
journalistic?
Well,
I don't,
I don't know so much if there's,
if you can characterize it yet as a demise.
It's certainly a transmutation because journalism is taking all sorts of new
forms.
It's emerging and many new forms online and in print and also on youtube and in
podcasts.
We're definitely in the midst of a technological revolution.
And I think that there's a proclivity on the part of the traditional media,
let's say,
uh,
to,
to panic,
to fail,
and to use increasingly desperate means of attracting attention while that's
occurring.
And it's easier to attract attention in the short term with heavily polarized
views and opinion pieces and that sort of thing.
And it's like clickbait,
I suppose it's,
yeah,
that's right.
It's the,
it's the,
it's the mainstream media equivalent of clickbait.
It might be a reasonable short term strategy,
but it's a deadly longterm strategy for any credible news organization because
credible news organizations live and die by their reputation and reputation is,
are easily lost.
And so I think that what happened with the Channel Four interview was,
uh,
it was an example of journalistic reputation being lost because there was almost
a complete disconnect between the person that Kathy Newman thought she was
talking to and me.
And,
you know,
she should have noticed that I would say,
let's say she had reason to be hostile and suspicious to begin with.
Um,
we,
we could,
we could give her that,
but hypothetically by a few minutes into the interview with seven or eight
minutes after four or five questions didn't go the way that she thought they
might go,
I would have been much more appropriate for her to default back to a normal
conversational tech instead of treating the encounter like a forum for victory.
I think that was her mistake fundamentally.
And the mistake of what many journalists is to think about it as something as a,
as a forum to attain victory.
Oh my son could gels to journalistic
Justin.
Yeah.
It was dominance,
hierarchy,
maneuver match essentially.
Yeah.
So,
and I didn't want to play that game particularly.
So.
So when um,
there was feedback afterwards and she had said that she thought the interview
went well and she didn't know what the role cast is about God.
Who was about,
do you see from the Union perspective?
Cause that,
cause that's my background.
I'm looking at it from is there the capacity and the propensity because self
reflection does,
does a person not to see it.
Okay.
I don't,
I really don't know.
I mean,
I would say if you're thinking about it from a union perspective,
that it was a good example of animus possession.
Right?
You can see that quite,
there are many examples of that online.
Um,
I've actually thought about making a video about that because anonymous
possession is a thing that's very difficult to describe,
but you can actually,
you can see it and certainly that's what happened with Kathy Newman.
It was blatantly on display.
Um,
I really don't know how she has responded to this.
I don't,
I don't know how you respond to something like that.
I tried to put myself in her shoes and to imagine that I was the recipient of,
well,
let's say lots of worldwide negative publicity essentially,
and,
and thousands of cutting comments,
you know,
ranging from pretty damning to extraordinarily damaging.
And I mean,
there's the odd comment that is in favor of what you did and stood up for her
combative nature and all of the outcome.
But I just don't know how you respond to that psychologically.
Uh,
it's,
it's gotta be,
you either shut it out,
which isn't helpful because you don't learn anything or you let it in,
in which case it has to be devastating.
So,
um,
all right.
Is there a notion,
um,
all,
if we go back to the young perspective of perhaps the transcendent function
coming into play where you are trying to hold the tension of opposites but
you're actually not doing that effectively?
Well,
the problem is I think in her situation is that because that that interview
failed so dramatically and so publicly that for her to bridge the gap between
her current persona,
let's say,
and the reality that was manifested in that video would require a very
comprehensive personality overhaul.
And that's a very unpleasant thing to do.
There's a lot of falling apart and burning away that accompanies that because it
isn't clear to me that she was wrong on a superficial level.
I mean,
maybe she was having an off day,
like it's possible,
you know,
and,
but I don't think that that video would have had the carrying power it had if it
was merely indicative of an otherwise competent journalist.
Having a bad day.
Yeah.
It seems to me that was a manifestation of a style that she's used quite
successfully in the past,
that,
that has had its short term expedient advantages.
But that is a,
is not a credible strategy for someone who's playing a deep and honest game.
So there's a lot of,
my sense was that the video indicated that there was a lot of work to be done,
but not only on her part because you know,
she,
she was involved in that personally,
but she was also the,
the mouthpiece,
let's say,
of an entire organization that was oriented to words,
having her do exactly what she did and,
and the,
you know,
what I expected to happen was that why have the interview and then channel four
would chop it and cut it according to their tastes,
which is essentially what they did for the broadcast and that the rest of it
would disappear.
I think it was unbelievably naive of them to put it up online,
but they did.
And uh,
well do they credit to some,
well,
I don't think so.
Maybe.
I think it was more,
they thought it went fine and then didn't understand what the fuss was about.
And then where they genuinely outraged that she was quote,
victimized.
Or was that just a cynical ploy to,
to spin the narrative in,
in,
in an acceptable direction?
I think,
you know,
a little of column a and a little of column B,
so,
but that also failed,
which was quite interesting because for about four days after the interview,
the narrative that victim narrative was picked up by many newspapers and spun
heart,
you know,
that there was security threats and that she was now in danger and there's no
credible evidence for that whatsoever.
But that came out,
there was a flurry of activity around that and then that just got criticized to
death and disappeared as a strategy.
So,
so would you say that it's possibly a part of the collective shadow manifesting
in projecting itself and maybe it was just become country?
Um,
I guess that the torch bearer for,
well,
I think that's often the case,
right?
I mean the media,
the media chases as much as it leads.
And so it's,
uh,
it's a,
a positive feedback loop between the media and the,
and the partners.
I mean,
that's partly,
I think what's driving polarization is exactly that.
And I think that the interview was an example of what's driving polarization.
And that's partly why people sat up and took notice of it.
It's like,
really,
this is where we're at.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
this is,
I mean,
is,
is there a place to bridge this polarization?
Perhaps that the perspective of holding,
holding the tension of opposites and being able to see critically both sides.
There's a philosophy that I followed for years.
I'm Daniel Dennett who's saying that you're wanting to engage in a discussion
with someone and,
and,
um,
move or progress the conversation forward.
That there are some steps to that including,
you know,
always.
Um,
what you say in chapter nine of your book is act as if the person that you're
talking to you or just need to have something to offer.
And it didn't seem apparent that that was the case and that,
um,
well that's the mistake I think.
Well,
first of all,
the two people who are engaged in the process of dialectic,
let's say you have to be of goodwill,
you know,
and,
and they have to be oriented I would say towards peace and they can be oriented
towards victory.
But then of course that's a combat and it doesn't,
perhaps it's sometimes the case that there are times when one conversation,
it should be combat,
but it's not very often that that should be the case.
Most of the time.
It should be,
what would you call it,
um,
uh,
peacemaking that you're devoted to because especially if you're discussing
something important and it should be assuming that you're able to trust the
other person,
which means they have to bring goodwill into the situation.
What do you want to do is bridge the gap because that's what forestalls
conflict,
right?
If you can't solve the problem,
then what you have is,
is,
is you have conflict.
That's,
that's it.
So,
and maybe you're ready for that.
And that's,
I suppose if you're ready for that,
well then that's,
that's how it goes.
But a wise person we'll,
we'll talk for a long time before they engage in actual conflict.
So yes.
Speaking of conflict,
do you think that in times of crises and chaos and conflict,
that's an architypes rise up and spring forth?
Like perhaps that trickster archetype?
Well that's Milo Yiannopoulos.
Yes.
No.
And comedians play that role all the time.
And comedians play a disproportionate role on,
you know,
on Youtube.
I would say in guiding the dialogue,
most of the people that I know,
they're astute political commentators on,
on Youtube and hoof attracted large following of a very large number of them are
comedians.
Would you call yourself,
um,
in October because you,
you do last night I was,
what do you know a wise person?
Make sure they stay dissociated from the archetypes
even if it gets put onto them because you,
you do seem to be the penultimate tell father pick up of the surrogate father.
Well,
that's not too bad.
That if that's the archetype,
that's not too bad,
you know,
I mean that's,
I,
I'm of the right age for that.
And,
and uh,
my,
my discussions too,
people are salutary so that,
that's,
that's a reasonable role to play.
I would say there's not too much psychological danger in that.
So,
and just one final question,
just in terms of your meteoric rise in the last two years,
I'll just say,
how has the start and being,
I mean,
um,
I was out there in the line,
the cues this today,
even just,
I'm misquoting the um,
archable Peyto down.
He said,
well,
he's quite handsome.
He's a quite good looking fellow in real life.
Um,
young men were quivering at the knees yesterday saying,
oh my gosh,
I've just met Jordan Peterson.
Elderly women were like,
wow,
I wish she wasn't married.
How do you take all that with a grain of salt,
with humility,
knowing that there's a spectrum between humility and Hubris?
I do know that you have close people in your core that
well,
I'm,
you know,
I was a psychotherapist for a very long time and you get accustomed to dealing
with,
with the variance of that,
I would say,
I mean,
you stay detached.
I don't mean,
I don't mean detached in that you don't care,
but you have to not have to stay outside of the drama in some sense.
I guess.
Like it isn't that you don't take it seriously,
but you see it for what it is.
No.
If people are star struck,
there's,
they're struck by a projection of their own imagination in large part.
I know.
And I can see that in people's faces.
And I try very rapidly to get over that.
And also,
so if someone comes up to me and they're nervous and they're sort of,
let's say starstruck,
for lack of a better word,
I can usually eliminate that immediately because I just talked to them very
directly and then they calm down and then we have a conversation that's much
better.
It's much better.
Yes.
I do see you doing that are very intense.
Um,
uh,
Dr. Peterson.
I am very grateful and thankful you having done this interview with me and I
really appreciate,
um,
the synchronicity.
Again,
I'm going by you and a lot because I'm Indian,
but the synchronicity of being here and being allowed to do that.
Do you do find that that's the part of your life as well?
Which the synchronicity.
Oh God,
you have no idea.
I would love to hear a story.
I heard y'all go,
yeah,
stories and the tap tap through to the car and the owl and you didn't go further
into that.
But I'd like to know if you care to share.
I can't,
they're too complex to layout.
Most of them have been associated with frog imagery.
I would say it,
but I can't say more than that because it's just too complicated.
No,
it's like trying to explain a dream.
It's very,
very hard.
Remember the dream that you recounted and I'm big on the Chantilly in the middle
of the,
did you,
did you end up resolving that?
Yeah.
Well I would say everything I've done since that dream is probably a resolution
of that.
I mean,
it's,
it was so,
thank you so much.
All right.
Very nice to meet you.
Nice talking with you.